hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well okay
so in in republic book one
there's a lot of arguments that are
being made that
discuss matters of like art or craft
or science or skill the the word
sometimes varies depending on the
translation
the greek word is technique the word
that we actually get technology and
technique from
and it means something like a you know
way of knowing how to do something
so medicine is an example piloting a
ship
is another example by piloting it
doesn't just mean you know running
the rudder he means actually running it
making sure it doesn't sink because the
sailors don't do things that they're not
supposed to do
agriculture is another example and now
think about your own
majors right every one of your majors
you've been studying something that
would tie in with us
you've been learning how to do something
and what is every skill involved well
there's some sort
of
subject matter
so if we take medicine for example
what's the subject matter of medicine
what what is the practitioner
human body is a big part of it nowadays
we have lots of technology
that we can you know mri and blood tests
those are
things that the skill uses i mean you
can give me an mri
and i don't know what i'm doing and i'm
not going to be able to do anything
useful with it
you can draw blood and hand it to me and
give me a you know blood test kit and
probably i'm not going to
be able to figure out how to do anything
useful with that either unless it has
really good instructions
there's also the practitioner right
right i'm just gonna put expert
because i can't remember how to call
that anymore okay so
skills always have some sort of expert
who works on the subject matter so a
doctor
or a nurse practitioner nurse
who else does medical things emergency
responders
anyone else doing medical well lab techs
are doing things with with the
medical anesthesiologists
we can name a whole bunch of different
subdivisions
now they have the skill
and that allows them to take the subject
matter whatever it is that the skill is
about
could be you know leather for a cobbler
who's making shoes
believe it or not you know shoes were at
one time mostly made out of leather
including the soles and what do they do
with that
they have some sort of
product which is always some type of
good right
and the skill
part of what it consists in are certain
standards
that's why i can't practice medicine you
shouldn't let me practice medicine
right i mean i i can do a couple home
remedies
you know and i know if you know if
you've got a sprain you should probably
take ibuprofen
not morphine um
but rather than anti-acid but i'm not a
doctor
even if i played one on tv you shouldn't
listen to me right you used to be that
old
i'm not a doctor but i play one on tv
and people are trying to sell you stuff
based on that
well no you actually want somebody who's
an expert should you let me run your
finances
i know a little bit about finances
wouldn't you be better off with somebody
who is actually studying finance
what do you think yeah
because they're more likely to achieve
that goal
that end that good that's distinctive to
that that skill
and now that that product or that good
is a good
or a benefit
for someone
is the doctor benefiting him or herself
primarily
by practicing medicine making money
yeah we're gonna we'll talk about that
in a moment um
but is that the is making money the
good that medicine is about it's a
byproduct
but it's not it's not be good if it
becomes the good
the practice of medicine becomes
corrupted
doesn't it that and two this is actually
a good point to like go
into some of this socrates says um
making money is the wage earners are
right and so alongside of it
this is it gets a little far-fetched at
this point is there really an art of
making money
uh that goes along with the art of
medicine i'm not really sure about that
um but you know
let's say at least you could do things
for more than one reason
there could be more than one thing
you're trying to achieve but the
question is
is what you're trying to achieve the
good of that particular art or
discipline
money isn't the only coin that you could
be paid in he says too
right what else does he say that you
could
try to earn as your wages
you remember it's kind of buried deep in
there
in the discussion
honor honor or praise or things like
that
people some people want to be paid for
what they do that's the main reason why
they're doing it other people want to be
looked up to for what they do
let's let's think just about education
for a moment
now if you actually get into education
because you have the idea of making a
ton of money
you're in the wrong field because unless
you
do something you know really unusual
you're probably not going to make a ton
of money
even right now the chicago teachers that
are on strike and people are saying
oh they're making so much money
they're also you know 35 students a
classroom and they
have to buy their own supplies and bring
them in
it's not a picnic my aunt was a chicago
public school teacher for years and by
the way
i say all that i'm not a supporter of
the union by the way
but educators are not highly paid what
about their social position
do you think somebody might become an
educator because
they want the praise or the admiration
or something like that that goes along
with it
that's plausible could there be other
things
that people might want besides the good
of their profession
i think anyone would become an educator
because they like being in charge
my mom used to you know when she was a
kid
she'd make all the other kids play
school with her
yeah and so she would you know get up
they didn't have a chalkboard she'd like
pretend but there's a chalkboard they're
just sitting on the steps
in chicago and she'd make the other kids
be the students and back then it was you
had to shut up and do what the teacher
said
and so she was you know all about that
and she would say hey you'll get a turn
later on
and my uncle's main complaint was we
never actually got a turn
because once she was in charge you can't
question the teacher right so it was a
kind of a self-serving thing now do you
think anybody
gets into education for those sorts of
reasons
i've seen some people
what's the actual distinctive good of
education
yeah i mean you teach kids well that's
that's what you
that's your your activity what what
should happen with those kids
gets yeah that's not a bad way of
putting it they get smarter
they come out with knowing something
that they didn't know
maybe you actually improve them in some
way and that's a benefit to them
you getting paid is not a benefit to
them you
being looked up to is not a benefit to
them that's a benefit to you
right and so when thrasymachus and
socrates are going back and forth about
this
thrasimicus is focused primarily on the
benefit to the
the expert the practitioner socrates is
noting
that with any of these sort of tasks or
activities or skills yeah
one second i was gonna say like
what's the prestige thing though when it
comes to being an educator like that can
be
beneficial to them
what to the to the students yeah like
let's say that you're the most
prestigious philosopher teacher
in on earth right now and we study under
you
like you know i see what you're saying
yeah
if you're studying with people who are
big names then you sort of um
gain some of their their juice their
their box either whatever you want to
call it yeah that happens you're right
um there there are people who um
associate themselves
with the big names precisely they didn't
get prestige like you know like harvard
has like a prestigious thing
by going to harvard by you saying you
can study that hard
yeah and i'll actually say something and
i have no problem saying this on
camera actually because i've said it
many places and times
i've not been highly impressed with the
people from the ivy league that i've run
across
as being more intelligent or better
informed
or better scholars or anything than the
rest of us ramadans
you know who went to state colleges
um whether they were high tier or vote
here i'm not saying that they're
any dumber than the rest of us
and they usually have really nice
libraries and access to lots of
good things i just haven't been
impressed with them being superior
you know i haven't been impressed that
they are superior to the rest of us
yeah i don't want to go too far out of
the sticker yeah
because it's because it was going to say
what you were going to say about ivy
league like i've never
believed either like they're just
they're just paying for the name they're
not actually
performing at a certain level like
that's how i always thought yeah i mean
it's like a social class thing
the social class is an important part of
the ivy league and the big state schools
too the well-endowed ones
yeah i mean you can get a good education
really anywhere you go if you really
want to work at it
but you know you think that your
professors should be part of that right
the practitioners
think about other skills now think about
where you're going
because right now you are
except for any of those of you who are
seniors right now
you are halfway to being a
first step practitioner in whatever it
is that you're studying right
in your major
you are on your way to becoming an
expert you're at the intermediate stage
you know more about your major
right now i'm willing to bet than i do
do you think that's probably the case
right i mean i may have studied some of
the stuff that you guys studied but it
was
a long time ago so you ought to know
more about it
what is the subject matter that you're
working with
some of you are going to be educators i
remember there's a lot of education
people in this class so
we've already looked at that what's the
subject matter what it is that you're
teaching but also
you're working with your students right
what other majors did we have a lot of
in this class a lot of business majors
didn't we and what else business
accounting communications
oh yeah a lot of comm majors i think
there was one cj
major maybe
well let's just take business think
about that for a moment
um that hand under that that worksheet
that i gave you
you could arrange all of these sorts of
ideas
for what it is that you're studying if
you're doing business
it's not just about making money
there's more to it than that right
what who is the expert it kind of
depends on one of the return on
management or finance or
or marketing i know but let's let's say
we want to be really really
bare bones with this the expert is is
maybe the entrepreneur the business
person
who knows something the
at least the successful one no one knows
what they're doing
not the ceo just before the company
crashes
what is the subject matter business
okay those are yeah whatever it is that
that company actually
does yeah i'm gonna say the subject
matter is just money
pretty much it is and it isn't because
there's a lot more to it than just
just money money is is going to be what
you use to measure just about everything
and it's what's changing hands but what
else is important if you want to be a
good
let's say we just take marketing and
sales you want to be a good salesperson
you got to know more than just about
money right what else do you need to
know about
having good people yeah you have to have
those what we call people skills and
those are skills
those are actual you know you may not be
able to put them
out there in an articulate fashion but
you have to be able to figure out what
makes people tick it's what we call
psychology
right what are you going to say i was
going to say um
maximizing like shareholders and stuff
yeah
learning where the inefficiencies are to
get those out of the way to raise
raise revenues yeah i was gonna say like
understanding your customer and what
they want
very important too yeah a lot of a lot
of businesses have
screwed up by uh taking their customer
for granted right
now in business it might be actually
easier to you know point what is the
actual product but it's not always just
the thing that's in the box that you're
selling
maybe you're i mean if you think about
certain brands
yeah go ahead and say you're pretty much
selling the name if you're selling your
brand name
like yeah you're not gonna buy like
you're gonna buy a ge refrigerator
because they know ge products
last forever and they're reliable yeah
now now you're hitting on something
that's a good
and it's not just the the tangible good
that you've got it's something else
right like security
reliability being able to be confident
that
at least that part of your house isn't
gonna break down you know
uh we say the same thing with cars
sometimes you're also selling an
experience
starbucks made it big by
selling a certain kind of ethos now
they've you know managed to
lose that process they became very large
and you know their coffee
went from being you know like handmade
each time to you know these measured
shots and stuff like that
but originally they were selling
something else
and that was good for people and that's
why people bought it and that's why
people
went in there that's why they opened up
all over the place
and if uh but you know if a company
quits being
or a practitioner quits being a benefit
to other people
they're not going to be considered to be
a good practitioner very long are they
and in business how what happens they
they the market turns against them right
and they go out of business why because
other people are doing the same thing
what about other arts um
you know this is this is a question you
can ask of anything that you're going to
study
anything that you're going to be engaged
in that has some sort of standards
that tell you what a good product is
what a good performance is think about
music
music is awfully subjective isn't it
but can i just like go and get some pots
and pans and bang on them
and get a record deal maybe probably
you think so then i put it on youtube
and then i catch on the pop banger guy
i i don't think so um because there's
probably
other people out there already doing
that and they don't seem to be
particularly successful
if you want to become a musician what do
you have to do
are any of you musicians playing
instruments
what do you need to do to become good at
us practice
yeah i just practice fun none
yeah as a matter of fact honestly a good
portion of it is
going to be boring i mean what do you
play
violin oh yeah a very demanding
instrument well
did you raise your hand oh another
demanding history i play
that's not a hard instrument i used to
play the bass guitar
which actually is more demanding than a
banjo
probably one of the reasons i play the
banjo now but if you want to get good at
it you got to do a lot of scales don't
you
and then after scales you got to do
other exercises and
if you all if you want to get good at
things you also have to listen to other
musicians you have to master a certain
corpus you can't just do whatever you
feel like doing
the art or the the skill of the
discipline imposes certain standards on
you
if you want to be a good practitioner
and
if you're a musician now of course
that's a little bit different isn't it
because
when you play the violin you probably
enjoy
it yourself right so the product that
you're creating
is in fact a good to you
but you're not going to get hired just
to play whatever you feel like playing
right
the life of a musician is still a life
mainly of pleasing the patrons whoever's
paying you and it you know
if you are benefiting someone
then you're probably going to be a
successful practitioner